mike breen espn/abc NBA NBA play by play
voice and of course the Knicks
play-by-play voices well brainy doing
his fourteenth NBA Finals and he'll be
joined by Jeff Van Gundy Doris Burke and
Mark Jackson and Mike Breen joins us on
the program good morning Mike dan oh I
could not agree more about the Ray Allen
shot if his form was just a little bit
better I can't even imagine the career
you would have had best shooter you've
ever seen in person was who you know for
three years I said Dell curry in terms
of just smoothness quick release perfect
form klay Thompson might have the
prettiest shot I've ever seen now in
terms of again quick release perfect
form
he's right there by the way the Dan
Patrick what kind of enticements do you
provide those who go on the app I can go
and watch the show whenever you want
there's there's a bonus content there's
shirtless photos on there I had my shirt
off yesterday for a little while in the
program like just let you know that's
what we that's what I'm prepping for the
finals is only the only I can what's the
strangest thing you've heard courtside
during a game by the players players to
player yeah that's a hard one to kind of
pinpoint I remember Kevin Kevin Garnett
Joakim Noah was a huge Kevin Garnett fan
and he gets into a game and it's a free
throw so they're lined up along the
free-throw Lane and Noah says something
to the effect of yeah I just wanted to I
am I'm a big fan of always you know kind
of always rooted for you and Garnett
looks at all his teammates and looks
back at the Boston bench I got one I got
that was one of my favorite ones gar
that was just he was just brutal in
terms of getting in guy's head just
brutal I tell the story and it was told
to me by a good source that Tim Duncan
and kg were riding the elevator together
at an all-star game just those two and
kg started yelling at Tim Duncan right
into his face and Duncan you know
there's no cameras there and Duncan just
didn't move I guess he didn't say a word
he just stared straight ahead and kg was
trying to get into his head or
intimidating and Duncan was having
nothing of it he was just like you know
stoic well draymond Green says the same
thing that he tried to yell at him and
he would always yell at him and he said
Duncan would just look at him like he
would stand there like a tree and
draymond says I just I gave up he's the
only guy I gave up on talking stuff to
because it didn't it had absolutely no
response and no impact do you have a
drink camera for the finals so that's
smart how much coverage is the proper
amount of time the Drake needs exposure
okay the Drake factor though is this
Doris Burke going to have an interview
with Drake in Game one well we have I
guess and it's just a guess it's just
speculation which we all love to do my
guess is yes we're talking to Mike Breen
and Breen II just doing his fourteenth
NBA Finals what were you like on your
first NBA Finals you remember I probably
the most nervous I've ever been in my
life prior to the finals I had heard
from several people above that I needed
to to take a different approach because
many of the viewers who watch the finals
had really never watched the NBA
there are many casual viewers who didn't
know a lot so I was told I had to do a
little more of a generic explaining type
of presentation and that just threw me
for a loop so I know this is I'm
probably exaggerating this but I felt
like I was saying things when a guy got
fouled I would say well now he'll go to
something called it's called the charity
stripe I was so nervous and I did the
game fortunately with UB Brown and I had
done up so many games with with UB and
after the first time out he could sense
that I was like sideways and he grabbed
my arm and he looked me in the eye and
he said kid just do what you always do
and it completely relaxed me and after
that I was I stopped explaining silly
things so that's that's how nervous I
was like you go from during the regular
season you call the Knicks games and you
have some of the most intelligent
basketball fans watching NIC games not
running the Knicks but watching the
Knicks games and then you go to the NBA
Finals where you have to be a little bit
you know more of an explainer there
that's got to be a tough transition you
know it's the hardest part of it because
you don't want to insult the people
who've been there all year but at the
same time there are certain things that
you do need to explain there are certain
players who you know a lot of people out
there have no idea of their history so
it's a way of doing it
without insulting the people that know
everything because you drive those fans
and those are the fans that are you know
the rabid fans that you want to take
care of too so you throw in phrases like
you know for those of you who have not
heard or for those of you who don't know
just at least appease them so they're
not throwing things at the television
and screaming at you we just stop
stating the obvious you idiot because
because you do have to find a balance
that's that's probably the hardest part
you think Durant plays in Toronto
I don't know my speculation is no I know
that he came here so everybody thinks
all right he's probably got a playing
game too but from what I've heard he's
still you know that calf injury it
really is one of those that it can be
two weeks or two months and it's been
exactly I think it's exactly a month
since he heard it so maybe it's getting
close but those injuries are like the
new plantar fasciitis in that you just
can't tell and when you think it's fine
all of a sudden you're you push off one
time and you're back to square one so I
think they're obviously going to be
really really really careful my students
at the broadcasting school that I have
there are play-by-play or you know
students who want to do play-by-play and
I didn't like my voice doing
play-by-play I I don't know and I was
comparing myself to the Great's of the
game so I just never I couldn't find my
voice and I don't know if that sounds
strange to you though Mike but how do
you how do you find your voice if you're
telling students who want to do
play-by-play what is your voice and how
do you know if you found it I don't
think at least for me I can only speak
for myself yeah I don't think you're
ever fully comfortable with how you
sound
there's always something that bothers
you about about how you sound and you
don't think it's right what I've always
done in terms of you know trying to
critique myself or listen for things
I've always found is there's a handful
of people that I rely on who all have
listened to a game and I know they're
going to tell me the truth you're not
just going to say hey you did a great
job last night people that that some of
our in the industry some people are just
fans who watch games at home you know
these are close friends who I rely on to
tell me the truth about my voice about
my presentation stuff like that that
have been really helpful because I think
it's hard to critique yourself sometimes
along those lines what I do find is I'm
enjoying my voice more now because my
hearing is going so I don't quite hear
and I remember back I think you were on
the call in 2004 malice at the palace
was that right yep what do you when did
you know that that it was going to be
bad and what could you see from your
vantage point we were on the other side
of the benches so we had a great view of
it and you know I did Nick games with
with Charles Oakley and and and Anthony
Mason so I had actually called quite a
few basketball fights so I actually had
I felt like I had some good blow-by-blow
experience going into that and so what
happens and it's you know it's a typical
there's a shove there's two guys have to
be separated but it never seemed to end
the scary part about it was that every
time one fight was broken up another one
would start and then especially when the
players were in the there were more than
one I mean our test was the first one
that went into the stands but then there
were several in the stands and you watch
the fans coming from from the higher
levels down and that's when I said oh
this this is really bad because it
seemed like there were fans that wanted
to protect themselves or protect their
fellow fans and it just seemed like it
didn't end it felt to me like it went on
for 45 minutes and it was only obviously
for a couple of minutes because the the
security is as hard as they tried they
just they couldn't seem to stop it
completely and then you're trying to
gather yourself because you know like
now what do we do
and is the game continuing and you know
they're taking players off the court
like how do you sort of in real time
gather all the pieces of the jigsaw
puzzle here well the game was suspended
and they had to get the Pacers off the
floor and there's one of the things that
always sticks out of my in my head from
from that night it's a very small narrow
walkway to get to the visitors locker
room so they had to shield themselves
because as they were walking out the
Pacers now fans were pelting them with
like full bottles of water whatever they
could put their hand on and
I remember seeing there was a woman
right by these two guys who were just
they were throwing as much as they could
and she was very nicely dressed and I'm
thinking to myself oh this poor woman in
the midst of this mob and then all of a
sudden the woman pulls out another
bottle of water and just pelts one of
the players in the head with it and I'm
thinking to myself this is this is a
true indication of what a mob mentality
is like because this woman probably
would have never done that in her life
but she got caught up in the emotion and
the volatile tension that was in the
indie arena
it really was scary it's the only time
I've ever felt that scene was scary
where people could get really hurt and
I'm amazed that nobody was seriously
hurt Michael be on the call
tomorrow night is 14th NBA Finals on ABC
and what time you guys get started at
the arena yeah what time are you on TV
it'll be a little tipple be a little
after 9:00 Eastern and I think we do
some pregame hits between 8:30 and 9:00
still still waiting on the schedule why
can't we bump it up a little bit here
you know what needs to be done like just
just say I asked and I said please like
can we start the game at 8:30 pregame at
8:00 get there at 8:30 let's go the
politeness thing please won't work it's
got to be more confrontational I am
gonna rip the hell out of this broadcast
if you guys my way of tell the boys I
said hello and great to great to talk to
you Mike thank you thank you know that's
a Mike Breen he's the voice for the
mothership 14 NBA Finals and I remember
when he first took over and we shared
the same agent and my agent goes how do
you think Michael do and I go I don't
know if he can make the transition from
doing the Knicks to doing the national
play-by-play because you almost it's not
watered down but it's it's a different
audience that you're appealing to not
knowing just how talented Breen was
because I'm listening to him on the
Knicks and I'm wondering can you do that
on a national level and he certainly has
been able to do that and then some and
with Mark Jackson and Jeff Van Gundy and
Doris Burke that is a great team for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]